it'd be hard for me not to bet on this
Jake's my guy but Nate's a dog you know
but if he's not taking it serious it's
it's gonna be a tough night yeah I'm in
the same boat I think the same is it
well it depends on how serious Nate
takes it regardless though Nate never
really been known for being hard to hit
he's never been known for like damn his
head moving slick Jake can deliver a
punch and with those boxing gloves and
you wrap your hand like a cast you can
get more power on those boxing gloves
with a right hand than you can with the
MMA gloves I think so you know we'll see
we'll see Nate can take that right hand
at that 185. Nate's not a 185 that plays
a role huge fan of both guys I've always
went for Jake and every fight I'm not
necessarily going for one or the other
just a massive fan of what they're
they're both doing and very excited for
it